Hi all.
Today we are going to talk about
a subject that usually does not
get the attention it deserves.
Money!
Why?
Because if you wish your startup
to last, it must be profitable.
There is no other way.
>> And, you should think of
your business funds as air,
as long as you have enough of it you
don't have to think about it at all.
But the minute you run out of it,
it's game over.
>> I'm Ido Green and in the past 20
years I've started six companies.
Two companies were acquired,
one became profitable, and
three flew into a wall
just like Buzz Lightyear.
Currently I'm having fun at Google as a
developer advocate helping startups and
developers get the most
out of monetization.
>> And I'm Jess, a program manager and
course developer here at Udacity.
My role in this course
is to ask questions.
Questions of Ido on how we monetize.
And questions of you, to help you start
thinking about how you'll apply what you
learn here in your own product.
>> In this course, you'll learn
basic monetization principles for
a variety of product types,
how to implement these strategies, and
how to track their effectiveness.
Let's take a little look
at how we'll do this.